I think he'll be the best at Kim  Kardashian dazzling like a diamond in  can talking her weight loss goals and  what kind of dad Rob's gonna be have you  and Kanye given Bob any advice with the  baby yeah we give I mean it's so  exciting you know it's a really exciting  time for him and we give him I think  more me you know gives him advice and  it's just been a really fun time and if  dad do you think Rob will be I think  he'll be the best at you've posted a lot  about your weight loss congratulations  you're looking amazing have you reached  your goal I've reached my pre-baby goal  but you know I'm a few pounds still to  go but I want to be before pre baby like  five years ago so in that I still have  15 to go  but I'm happy and I feel confident and  I'm very happy  you